yes Sina is with us in Dallas is it you
Cena is that correct
it's Yesenia thank you so much for
taking my call are you talking to who I
thought my husband has over 75,000
dollars in debt from a trade school
which was closed down last year and we
have been deferring payments for the
last two years it's currently in a
lawsuit we don't know if to start paying
no or not it's accumulating interest
we're not even 100% sure if there are
several laws on the books
is this a Sallie Mae student loan or a
private student loan it's a private
school loan owed to them yeah oh no no I
take that back no no no it's not private
no okay all right so it's the Sallie Mae
loan or it's just a bank loan okay if
the if the trade school has been closed
down or is gone broke that debt goes
away that's the no okay now he actually
received his degree so oh but he hasn't
found a good he's not using his Vickery
at the moment so what does it matter
that is old school closed down if he got
his degree one more time what does it
matter to you that they closed down if
he got his degree
well got his degree I know but he didn't
receive that education that you know he
needed he's not working in the field
that he you know what do you learn he's
not competent in that field
well it's he got his degree for
cybersecurity currently he's in helpdesk
yeah my question is does he know what
he's doing on cybersecurity or not no no
he does not
okay so his degrees worthless it's
worthless because he got no knowledge
all right and you have seventy three
thousand dollars seventy five years I
would contact an attorney okay and there
are some provisions that when a school
goes
broke while you're there that that the
debt is forgiven there's some federal
laws on the books regarding that it has
some there's some caveats to it and so
forth then you need to learn about those
that doesn't apply here because he's
graduated but I think you've got it you
make a case that they were incompetent
and that the loans were taken out on a
fraudulent basis for that reason because
I'm sure this the people making these
loans were tied into the school yeah I
mean they're sitting there at the desk
in the school right yeah so I would
contact an attorney and see if there's
any any legal outs that you have here
because basically what you're telling me
is you got ripped off that you were told
he was going to be taught something and
he really wasn't learning anything and
that you know now you know it's hard to
believe what why did he keep going if he
wouldn't learn anything you know I mean
at some point you gotta go I'm really
don't know what the crap I'm doing and
I'll keep paying for this you should've
pulled the plug on it long ago
that's the other thing that's going on
here so hey good question thank you for
joining us